really bad anxiety when I was on that
show I was talking about yeah I did
little things I try to do like uh
meditation TM I do that it's real
helpful yeah that's helpful
um the one guy was Jeff Bridges he saw
me when I was on the show I was really
nervous and he told me his story he said
you know when I was
um I was an Iceman Cometh with uh Robert
Ryan and every time before every take he
would get nervous and he and I said wow
all these years you still get nervous
and he said yeah I'd be really afraid if
I wasn't afraid and I was like oh that's
interesting and Jeopardy was like so
yeah that's that's your buddy man
is that that anxiety that's your buddy
man you know put your arm around it and
just get out there man yeah it's good
you know and I'm like oh okay